welcome back everybody to the h3 podcast
live today we have a very special
illustrious guest jenna Marbles
superstar and her boyfriend another
superstar Julianne
so let me die today we are sponsored by
me undies and Bethesda and our third and
probably our best sponsor of all time
ourselves check it out
we made a ro merch store I'm really
excited to share with you guys at h3h3
shop comm check it out we've got an
internalized oppression shirt pretty
great comfy cozy love the fabric yellow
what do you got I got a matter of long
stick it to the haters with this matter
of lost shirt let him know that when it
comes to litigation you are a matter of
law that applies to like one out of a
million people but you know and there's
two more really cool ones we just don't
have them here yet girl show it but so
yeah you
we don't have specially they're
especially dedicated to you guys who
watch the podcast well these are
actually my favorite ones you've got the
fascinating and the right there the
colors are insane so cool and I've lost
all respect for myself which is a
podcast me but it really implies to
anybody could apply to anybody so if you
guys want to support the show hit up
h3h3 shop comm and pick up your slammin
hot merchandise by us for us FUBU
okay let's get let's get to business
here guys
look you guys all you guys all know who
jenna Marbles a seventeen million subs
on youtube but more than that she's one
of the longest-lasting like relevant
youtubers to I think she's been doing it
for like ten years
and beyond that she's a female which I
think does say something on YouTube it's
a tough it's tough out there for females
on YouTube and listen her boyfriends
know
do you come into his own he's got one
point three million dollars vlogger it's
like 10 degrees outside we've got the AC
blasting but it's just not enough it's
really I'm freezing here I always have a
jacket here yeah it's it's probably like
85 in here and the AC is on blast we
just installed a new garden cuz we're
moving houses and we had like the
landscaping done in the backyard and the
these poor plants they're dying these
are like low-water desert plants and
they're dying they've actually been
burned yeah you'll burn yes so that's
how we're doing how you guys doing
well anyway enough about us and you guys
know who Jenn and Julian are so let's
bring them out I'm screaming this is me
screaming I said I'll scream when we're
ready for them so this is me screaming
yeah thanks for coming appreciate you
guys been all good good yeah yeah good
who sang to us usually like a cool 65 in
here and I'm pretty sure this room was
like 80 right now it's muggy this I feel
like coming in here that's good
you know all the plebs and the Internet
all right yeah I just sweat now I prefer
that I know they're suffering you know
what I mean
no I just wanted to so yeah cool well
what are you guys working on lately
what's good man we do we do one of these
except it's on the scale of like 1/10
it's like in our little room at ration
there's a three c100 yeah actually we
kind of need to get more cuz it's a
little inconsistent because you have
öyou different cameras yeah yeah yeah
it's a little unconcerned about having a
couple in the back just we've been
meaning to that for so long and I keep
delaying it it's expensive
we want to see 103 years ago using it
for it's our baby every week you guys
use that for your main videos mostly
podcasts the occasional video you shoot
your podcasts on it yeah yeah yeah by
the way I like you guys at 72 I mean
yeah it's it's it's really effect you
know you don't need all the bells and
whistles necessarily we started it just
like on a laptop so for us we've come a
long way we used to have a camera it was
like a $200 handy cam from Best Buy
and it would only focus on one of us at
a time really so every podcast you guys
are on the same like yeah cool yeah it's
like we're doing your podcast over two
years I think only supposed to close it
through yeah those are veterans yeah and
same with twitch which is crazy because
we do in like the same setup in the same
room the only thing is like we don't
broadcast on twitch with all the good
cameras it's like a little webcam and
stuff down you down scalpers yeah yeah
switches twitch has been a lot of fun
lately as we played this no I prefer
that the viewers well if it's not just a
straight-up inception screen of like
when you have this yeah you did that I
was watching the other night you had
like 50 yeah that's effective people
like that so that was on purpose yeah
it's just I'm trying to entertain but I
would assume that there's horrible echo
there's nothing to complain about it's
actually really funny somebody listening
with headphones because I'm always like
I have no idea by the way we're talking
about pub G which is
the twitch Renaissance yeah we're all
been playing yeah yeah and this [ __ ]
game drives me crazy like I love it and
I hate it you know some games are a joy
okay this game especially when this game
is Imperium it's imputing yeah but when
it's good its I don't want to do
anything else
yeah well because the games last like
what an hour yeah I think it lasts like
45 yeah yeah yeah so usually what
happens for me is that all drop in some
obscure place the game is basically a
huge open map with a hundred people and
it's just a battle royale and I'll drop
into a tiny little like farmhouse that
nobody's there because I know it can't I
came not gonna take them I'll lose
immediately I'll lose all these houses
I'll play like super secret I'll crawl
through a wheat field burn out for like
30 minutes
and then the moment I see something like
either either somebody will shoot me and
I'll have no idea where they are
that's the worst yeah and the other one
is just like it happened yesterday
dude crawls up I'm right in front of
them with the shotgun missed three times
and he just turns and kills me
immediately yeah so yeah I hate the game
I'm like the only times I play I drop at
the farm like literally the farm and
then just try to survive is that a
specific yeah yeah oh no the map is well
you have the names of the cities but
then they have like a school and farm
and right right right
farm but you did get us a nice little
dinner that one test show which was so
pretty bugger
reviewing that pretty it wasn't that
guy's day no yeah no yeah I think he
didn't he must have been not reloaded
his gun or something cuz yeah well
you're like a bro to how pleased I play
with actually we did play with a pro the
other night yeah one of our regulars one
of our friends in the torch community
zombie unicorn she's dating a guy named
accent he's a pro he was a pro csgo
player now he's in the tournament syrup
pub G and he jumped in one of our custom
games and he just completely demolished
everyone and we were we knew it was
coming he just you hated him yeah we we
set up a custom games it was like groups
of three of all of our friends he just
hunted us down I don't understand I'll
watch blowpro players play yeah that's
hard to say
and they just see everybody hmm
they shoot I don't understand how they
see everybody because I don't see [ __ ]
yeah I've got a big monitor good
graphics they move around like it's
there where they grew up your shroud
yeah I've checked about has a machine I
like watching that [ __ ] doctor
disrespect I know it's like a meme but
he's pretty oh yeah that's watching him
and I did play and they won six games in
a row as well because we subscribed lol
he read our name because that's all he
did too and we lost did he acknowledge
like oh I know them always seems not
very generic Wow like a thousand subs
right that was special though oh yeah
big moment as well congratulations
thank you so anyway getting off the pub
to you as much as I loved it
yeah we nice to see boobs that's for you
oh it's just it's a special message and
thanks boots
yeah thanks guys Austin puts Malone
lifted there Oh hit me this label maker
huh well we have a label maker and he
somehow got his hands on it yeah and
he's just left you know what's funny cuz
a lot of times people will be like why
does it say boobs but a lot of times
people won't even say it at all which is
kind of easier to know yeah all right
let me take limit I want to ask you
something okay um obviously me Neela
make videos together she's a female and
I've seen what it's like for a female on
YouTube but you've been doing it for so
long you're good you're like how long
have you been doing YouTube like ten
years
my first channel I think I made in what
was it 2007 it but then I had to stop
that cuz I had my full last name in it
my mom was oh wait so marbles isn't your
last name no it's my dog's name
so you originally made it with your real
name
yeah and what was your mom I'm sad about
that because she was trying to get a job
at the time so like her name is Deborah
Maury mine's jenna mourey and right so
that was at a time on the internet where
you know even a facebook page was like
you type it you find it yeah so um she
just asked me to make another one so
made jenna Marbles in like 2009 I think
hmm was the first channel big okay
so nothing lost there no yeah so it's
been probably like eight years for my
main channel yeah so how is it I mean in
your experience as a female do you think
that you get a different shake on
YouTube I mean you you definitely get
some more like awful comment like real
fucked-up [ __ ]
I've yeah but um not bad but as long as
you have a thick skin about it yeah I
mean some of that shit's dark definitely
I remember how many times do you get
Jenny is pregnant
called alive all the diamonds so funny
if I just look like a little bit better
one day quite like that we got do it an
awful car accident like no no we
couldn't work out for like eight months
you guys were like because I'm on
they're constantly like bitching and
moaning like hey guys can't work out
sorry for getting a little [ __ ] back
let's go do you wish that pub G was
around during that accident yeah would
have been a lot more productive I just
think I just first have been so much
better by now what are you guys doing
that time yeah that how long was it you
said nine months I was in October so no
it was like my meat I still can't feel
part of my knee
well um but like we we could walk I
could walk we could do stuff but like we
couldn't work out
she just mind talking about it like what
what happened with the yeah um so we
were on the in the carpool lane
so against the median on the 405 and we
were kind of approaching a spot we were
going like full speed like 70 and we
were approaching a spot where there was
like a traffic kind of jam up ahead but
it was one of those jams were like 400
yards behind it people are still going
full speed
yes yeah sigelei yeah so the guy in the
lane adjacent to us and ahead of us
pulls one of those others traffic Miley
and I'm gonna hop into the carpool yeah
I do the car like over double yellow
there didn't look we hit him pretty much
like full speed like kind of at an angle
cuz I had no time to react we didn't see
any of this mind you like we're on our
phones like all the sudden it was just
like well wait you're on your phones
okay you weren't driving
no sharing up here listening to deep
throat I cupcake yeah you guys were
having a moment
and then all the sudden there's like
shaking and it was like the most it was
the weirdest experience I've ever had
like you can't describe it but after
like it felt like ten minutes was just
like crashing we were stopped and we
were kind of bracing for cars to hit us
and no cars hit us luckily the woman
behind us hopped out called an ambulance
and checked on us and she was like about
passed out she was like really yeah you
know so wouldn't you guys crash like
what kind of injuries did you guys
sustained well she hurt her knee cuz her
leg was up and he was one of those
priests calves where they have like the
hard wall right and her knee just
slammed in the wall but immediately we
couldn't breathe
because the the seat belts they like
constrict when you crash and they like
compressing
chest so it was like like a lot of that
what is the thing with a an MRI aren't
you in the thing because I had like
pretty bad seatbelt and there's a lot of
girl parts there's like internal
bleeding
oh how is it going through the MRI it
was weird cuz they like I hate needles
so like it yeah I just have my chronic
back pain so do try so they're gonna
inject you and then do an MRI yeah I
guess I mean it just hurts like a shot
it's nothing anything worse than that
I hate it well it seems really open
how does it work they inject like ink
and there's like dye so that the MRI can
show whatever they're looking at you
know better contrast or whatever oh
there you go gonna be interesting yeah
you get to choose the color so did you
did this guy was there any repercussions
for this guy who rear-ended you guys yes
well so he actually getting rear-ended
he basically caused the whole thing but
are not rear-ended yes I he had four
other cars Wow
so and he was solely responsible oh so
he's in a world of hurt
so everybody's suing him all the
insurance well yeah what happened is
they filed a report so everyone's
medical bills just go to that guy oh my
god yeah that's gonna be millions yeah
it's a lot probably so what did he end
up covering you guys as a medical bill
yeah I mean it's still not done it'll be
done and probably yours cuz everyone's
got to finish their treatment and then
send in the bill so you guys paid for it
yourself yeah what happens if you don't
have money that sounds like me got lucky
on a number of fronts like hey we can
afford it right yeah but also we're
alive
you know it was a bad accident going
really fast and we survived so you know
the end of the day were super lucky yeah
we were couch potato yeah anyways I do
get called pregnant all the time and
it's a little offensive but like
not the worst thing in the world yeah
okay in short with a with a side being a
girl on YouTube well how's it for you
ela I mean I agree yeah it's you
definitely need to develop a thick skin
but I think that's for anyone probably
for you to like but it's weird it's
funny to see the different kinds of
comments like are you pregnant or
smiling afterwards there'll be a
screenshot of but no I mean I don't know
when I see like if I mention a female
youtuber generally I've noticed that in
the comments they get really [ __ ]
boner yeah towards them yeah whatever
what can you do that that like young
male demographic mm-hmm that's true
what is your demographic mostly girls it
was like teenagers and then it got a
little older as I got older aged with
you yeah interesting yeah my demographic
is 90% men which kind of shocks me and
it feels a little bad to be honest like
seriously like you know ela brings a
feminine touch yeah we're the ladies
that has it changed ever since you
started or has it been like pretty much
the same five out of every 100 women was
like I can tolerate this guy that's so
crazy man so you're said what is yours
it like roughly a percentage if you know
probably like 85 girls Wow
okay so we're kind of like the
to the system yeah ya know when I
started I like I was in my early 20s and
you figured that you're like making
content for people just like you right
you're like it's probably all my friends
and people my same age and then when you
rise it's like oh [ __ ] there's all like
teenage girls like my mind you know are
they like young men are they men your
age there I would say eighteen to late
twenties - I see a lot knowledge 18 to
35 really yeah try interesting name what
kind of people watch your videos Julian
a lot like Jonas I would say maybe maybe
a little more male but pretty pretty
much the same so you're just more
attractive thank you I wonder if I
exercise more I get fit if our female
demographic will go up you should fill
us don't equals female views you're at
the peak right now life yeah nice I just
want how'd you guys meet cuz you guys
are a cute YouTube couple yeah freaking
adorable cuties thank you we met at a
bar
he's a bartender and I relentlessly hit
on him that's true that's kind of like a
sitcom hangout what's usually the other
way around right like the guy picking up
girls in the bar you went I tell it did
he work there yeah I was a bartender and
I'd seen her multiple times because she
used to come in and it was at the end of
my street where I lived
so I walk there and then
yes like I would see her a lot and then
I think you like in a way you were like
hey like let's hang out like don't
bartend come hang up and one day I did
and then we start hanging up Warren then
the bar got closed down and yeah it was
like pad ownership and then the guy like
bounced out of town slowly alright I'm
good sleep nice and you started making
YouTube videos like what were you into
that stuff before you know not all I was
actually doing radio I worked for a
radio radio station in LA 97 1 amp radio
and then also I did radio in college so
I wasn't like a lot of old media so when
I met her she was like I met him he was
still into school which was like bizarre
I'm six years older than Julian yeah she
was still in school and he was taking
this one class where they give you this
footage of like a truck home or some
[ __ ] and it was his job to edit it and
you had to edit it like at the machines
like at school or whatever right and I
was like dude [ __ ] go ham on that
thing like you can do whatever you want
and but they teach you like this very
specific way yeah I made some TV
broadcast I didn't make Ford commercials
yeah but it was like make it weird like
do something crazy
yeah listen no I wanted to do and then I
got like a C on the thing okay why did
this is so arbitrary right it's like
you're making a car commercial we just
all supposed to do the same and that's
really what it was it was like be a
cookie cutter that reminds me when I
went to art school they made us take a
Photoshop class and the teacher he kept
teaching us like here's a picture of a
face of a model and now let's clean up
her face like remove a imperfections
fake yeah and it it really was weird to
do
I didn't I was not into it in a way
that's those are the jobs out there
those are the jobs that's what he was
teaching like that we sing with you mind
those same with mindless heading right
yeah it's like yeah that's the job yeah
but it's kind of it's a weird thing cuz
it's like art video editing Photoshop is
art but it really is just used like very
industrially I also studied art in
college did you really yeah it was it
sounds nice it's total joke then why it
was pretty much just the easiest major
to pass through school because it's like
who's gonna tell me my poetry sucks
right so you know arbitrary but you were
into it when we met you're downplaying
yeah I'm like a couple poems but you
know I hate poetry after I got it
College yeah and I came out hating it
where'd you go to school
UC Santa Cruz oh that's right and
where'd you go to school in Israel
Shankar it are you going to college yeah
where I went to Suffolk what'd you get
sports psychology and counseling is that
for like physical therapy kind of thing
what do you what's the application of
that um well there's lots of different
ones I was probably gonna work with kids
but uh
you it's typically for like performance
enhancement so like if I've been
athletes going through a slump or
something you would see a sports
psychologists mental aspect of their
game basically did you ever use that at
all not after I graduated are you going
to like YouTube almost immediately right
yeah pretty much
yeah well that sounds like would be an
interesting gig though yeah do you
remember any of those skills
sort of
you need some performance enhancement
yeah Oh dances the lights are flickering
really I didn't notice yeah it's only oh
he's saying we might get another
blackout oh man [ __ ] we were uh we did
this an episode a couple weeks ago and
the power just dropped and then for like
an hour so heads up if it goes out
that's why yeah
la baby I'm just waiting for it now back
out in a huge earthquake that's funny we
were talking with Dan about in like 97
were you you guys were far from LA so 97
was like basically the apocalypse in LA
because there was the Northridge
earthquake and then I think that same
year was like the El Nino you remember
that [ __ ] yeah I mean I was really
earlier and it was like the whole city
all of SoCal was flooded yeah that [ __ ]
was crazy I remember I had like this
river my backyard and it completely over
overfilled into the neighboring city
anyway where'd you grow God and Ventura
yeah so just south of here oh yeah so
I'm waiting for the next apocalypse
essentially yeah the block down to the
earthquake well we're ready we're on a
nice little shelter here yeah we're
ready here our house isn't ready house
is like leaks if it just like rains be
body yeah yeah we have a couple dead
leaks at our house besides we ran to in
socks you know the bag though Julian
made a really [ __ ] dope go bag what
is that just like an emergency emergency
yeah what it's in it you know it's um
like external power lights yeah are you
guys I'm not I'm not crazy about it but
I did like we we had like a blackout and
I was like okay next time this happens
we're gonna be ready and now put it
together
yeah but it's got like dog food in like
some people food in there so the dogs
he's right we're getting
Peach's gotten in there a couple of
times yeah so sick you guys have like a
nuclear fallout you guys ready for that
I don't have shelter but we have a guest
room the Holocaust like let's just you
know the nuclear is a shorthand well
like yeah let's just play pub G and wait
it out you know go to the pub and play
pub - you go to the plug yeah I like
that that's the future pub Jesus sets up
at the pub go have a beer you guys
you're into conspiracy theories that's
that's something you're deep into a
little - what else what are some of the
spicy ones that you're really into these
days because there's theories that are
just like how many ridiculous many parts
of the Avaya Podcast they saw there's
like three they have like conspiracy
theory part 1 4 - oh well here's my
question because there's a lot of
conspiracy theories that are just like
obviously joke like well correct me if
I'm wrong maybe I'm lizard people can we
all agree that that's just I mean I like
to entertain anything ok I want to know
why someone thinks that and like what
their reasoning is and I'll entertain it
I'm not sure I'll buy into it well a lot
of times I'm not sure if people actually
believe it that's part of experience
ears that [ __ ] with me because you're my
flatters like would this be fun yeah in
it I have a hard time stretching my
imagination and believing that there's
people that actually believe the earth
is flat and I don't know if it's an
elaborate troll no that's really like
that's okay that's true so what so what
Taylan tequila really believe I don't
know cuz every time we talk about it I
start to feel like they're all just
trolls yes but I don't know okay so what
and anyway so what are some of the ones
that you think are like oh there's
something to that um one of my favorite
ones is that Francis Bacon was William
chase
it's pretty brilliant that was pretty
good
yeah that is pretty strong actually
heard that stuff a lot that Shakespeare
was a pseudonym or even I've heard that
Shakespeare was a collective of a lot of
other writers have you heard that
no um I see the one that I liked was
that Shakespeare was a real person he
was like an actor in a play guy and
Francis Bacon is the one that wrote all
of those things interesting
used him as just like this figure that
would be take all the credit basically
but Francis Bacon wanted to get all of
these ideas into the public via pop
culture that being like writing and
didn't want it to be like associated
with him well that's that's interesting
yeah what is there like a lot of
supporting evidence for that yeah huh
because Shakespeare the history is kind
of weird on him right like there's not a
lot out there about the guy that's kind
of what adds to this conspiracy right
makes an interest that one's one of my
favorite ones that was the one we talked
about last night
yeah oh we talked about with a Mariah
Carey one do you remember in New Year's
Eve performance she's like I can't see
the words y'all just like walk like that
it was unsynched in her here losing my
[ __ ] job right so what's the
conspiracy theory because some people
were talking that's the giving her a lot
of credit or somebody sabotaged her not
even her people somebody sabotage that
situation to make it be like without her
knowledge it could have been either it
could have been with her knowledge or
without but regardless for the better of
the show doing well all right you even
like the Oscars stuff like I feel like
that's a thing that people would
consider like I think they're
potentially [ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah to get
talking about it I mean at this point
that does make sense yeah yeah you kind
of have to be wary because I feel like
you gotta cannot believe anything yeah
yeah yeah
trust nobody especially Mariah Carey
well what's like the serious [ __ ] what's
like is there any that you guys are kind
of into that it's like reality twisting
[ __ ] 9/11 [ __ ] oh man I mean I'm like
I'm Way too far down
most of those rabbit holes to be like a
[ __ ] normal person fascinated by UFO
stuff yeah yeah I just watched a
documentary on Netflix I frankly never
been convinced on the UFO thing I want
I'd like to believe it not convinced on
you know I want to believe I don't
believe that aliens visit earth I don't
believe that or at least I at least know
that's interesting at least I've never
seen compelling evidence to support it
cuz like you always have this super low
qualifies every footage of an alien
force the HD [ __ ]
where's the 4k [ __ ] I mean right I are
we were 4 km we were on the roof of
target oh yeah that was that was HD HD
US missile okay
that was spicy hot that's pretty sweet
just flew missile over the
second-largest city in a military
without a show of arms or something yeah
and I did I was pushing the propaganda
because they trying to flex I know they
knew some kid out there was gonna be
over the camera and I was and I love
that you guys were at the center of that
I remember she not on reddit on the
front pages are like alright UFOs exist
guys we did it like what it's you guys
yeah that was like right when we started
watching your guys's videos we're
wearing our hats like yeah
full circle so what I mean okay what
like give me the deeds convert convert
order yeah I mean I don't do it justice
but just [ __ ] watch ancient aliens
man oh it's a little crazy where you're
like a lot of it wait this is like a
History Channel show yeah yeah sounds
good you're telling me that there's no
chance or you find no evidence of people
like people or beings or anything beyond
this earth like you are the tippy-top of
everything that came out of the universe
you and your consciousness that's like
whoa what the [ __ ] it's not that crap
I'm in the-- but that's not what you
believe right you don't think that I
believe conscious someone you were at
the top of that I believe that other
life exists a lot of it throughout the
universe okay the fact that we exist on
earth and it happened like relatively
quick and the Earth's evolution right it
makes it seem likely to me or almost
like inevitable that it's somewhere else
but the question of if they have
visiting the earth hmm that's what I'm
skeptical what about the thought of like
them visiting without anyone ever
knowing like what surveiling like sure
see yeah I think that if they did they
would they wouldn't do that yeah what do
you think they're doing it's like a Star
Trek meme they're just like checking it
assess it as hell lots of theories about
that but that they basically created the
earth like they created the earth yeah
terraforming is where you take a planet
and you turn it into what you want it to
be right and then they put the moon
where it is would have a perfect
gravitational pull sorry for like water
and ocean and life to exist it's really
cool so your boy Elon Musk you yeah you
know it's not really
but he believes that were in like a
simulation I love it so like if there's
higher beings or other aliens or
something that created people or for
some I don't know dude no I'm saying
like you could basically be in a
simulation but that would require other
beings to have crazy oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah definitely it's a thought
experiment doesn't act it like be real
you don't have to buy into it but like
entertain the idea I love the idea yeah
I think he does know what terrifies AI
yeah I love that are you that you that
waits are well I've always thought that
people are too cautious about the future
of AI but you on someone I respect a lot
and trust his opinion so it alarms me I
mean I loved the discussion it alarms me
to see him so worried about AI but I've
always thought like it's so sci-fi right
like these killer robots it just seems
so far-fetched
I really would start as like a physical
like kill you yeah it would start isn't
like writing its own code its own
language and then finding out a way to
create laws to protect themselves and
[ __ ] us or like even if you made
something that was ethically driven no
all sudden you've taken all of the the
personal aspect out of being a human
being and the like here's what's right
for you right you can only do what's
right and wrong you know it seems more
likely that it would start from some
cyborg [ __ ] of like people start
mingling with computers do you see those
chips that they want to implant it's
like brightener [ __ ] I hate that so
there's wait but first of all I hate
black mayor it's way too depressing
name that show right there's this one
episode where I was like dude I've never
watched episode about a couple more the
guy dies you know yeah and then
get the doll yeah yes [ __ ] I was like
dude I'm not I'm here to chill I'm not
here to have existential dread no I
stopped watching ow my knees and Jenna
was like all right watch the next time
like what no no I need to go to therapy
now like talk about this there's also
that crazy one where he's like in the
house trip yeah it was great the end
kana was like a little hokey pokey
wasn't it was it was like 3 different
ends
it was just gnarly to think that like
his mom spoilers his mom calling his
phone right is what killed him
I guess is what we're led to believe cuz
he didn't put his phone in the tray like
he was supposed to and the phone set off
some sort of I don't know what I don't
remember but that one really was I was
not as a mind bender yeah yeah anyway
let's talk about UFOs okay what was I
you want musk oh yeah so everything you
should be worried about a eyes is our
own experience with the YouTube
algorithm are our video tower my video
talking about our car accident has been
like the monitors it's because that's
like right traumatic exactly that's so
that's AI being like it's all very
black-and-white
yeah it's it takes the human right
aspect out of it they're like this video
is it's just a cold analysis of data
right but now you apply that to like law
or medicine or ratings like dying we're
[ __ ]
I agree I agree it's scary but I always
thought if you're creating an actual
artificial intelligence the programming
itself just by its very nature you can
program in restrictions to they I or
yeah you're expecting an illusion oh
you're expecting it to fall it has to do
by the very law of its existence but
else they're like all the algorithms are
like self teaching so
yeah but there comes a point where you
not even following what they that's what
kind of roles they made for themselves
cuz the algorithm that you built might
be different than the algorithm it's
become yeah that's one aspect because
I'm sure there's like self learning
algorithm and then there's like
hard-coded yeah dudes chip but this is I
mean the YouTube comparison is really
good because they told us that they have
an algorithm that controls which content
gets the most watch time that's all they
care about is watch time and they don't
even know what the algorithm is doing
that's tearing hey they they're always
catching up and trying to understand
what the algorithm is doing that's crazy
so they're almost not even in control
like sometimes they'll sit down and
evaluate like what it's assessed is good
and maybe they'll make tweaks to it if
they're like oh maybe less spider-man
else' like yeah raping kids yeah yeah
what a weird thing man Alberto is that
gone now yeah it wasn't actually the
algorithm loved it and everybody loved
it but they demonetized it and so but
did it take like you guys exposing it I
don't know was it just kind of like I
don't know but it definitely took a
while yeah yeah we were talking about
that [ __ ] for a long time yeah but if
they made a new monetization rule that
says you can't have cartoon characters
children characters doing violent or
secretaries love although there's still
some spicy [ __ ] out there like
Cinderella and some skimpy outfits my
friends I mean that [ __ ] would work very
close to working on pornhub some of the
stuff I've seen Cinderella do on YouTube
let me tell you right now and I've
watched a lot of it for researchers only
recent science yeah purely research it's
bugged the Bradbury's and you should
absolutely okay he is a UFO
he is a alien creature your honor
tae-sik I feel like I want to get back
to that because I love that discussion
about UFOs mm-hmm so you you think it's
possible that the earth was created in
the moon
was created because it's such a perfect
like they call it the Goldilocks zone
right or a happen a planet is in perfect
habitable space to a star yeah I mean
won't listen I'm not like this isn't
something that I'm like this is the end
all be all right but I think that the
evidence is really interesting and
compelling that I like if someday we
found out that that was a real thing I'd
be like [ __ ] you god that means I mean
it doesn't make sense in the same way
that like intelligent design makes sense
yeah it just it's a nice explanation
yeah but there's lots of earth-like
planets they're finding now they've got
this new satellite called that Kepler or
some [ __ ] they're like is specifically
for finding earth-like planets and they
found like 50 60 70 that are earth-like
in the Goldilocks zone in our like
neighborhood cluster so there's a lot of
them out there that's relatively nearby
that's pretty exciting
let go I mean aliens are discovered the
alien theory is that that's like been
here the pyramids there's I thought they
figured it out who figured what out
they understand how they're built like
they figured it out I mean maybe I don't
know that so as I understand it they
just they figured it out like twenty or
thirty years ago how they made them yeah
so and it's really interesting there's
basically like on the interior of the
pyramid you have tunnels inside that
skirt all the way up mm-hmm so they drag
the stones basically from the inside
yeah from the inside and I was
accessible when they come I think they
covered them up on the way out see an
ancient alien theory they say that those
are like basically power beams right
they're perfectly aligned with the
constellation Orion and there's a bunch
of other ones like Teotihuacan in Mexico
or whatever it's it's built like like a
computer chip and there's a lot of
theories that there's like a running
power through it like it's some power
source
it's [ __ ] sick so maybe they figured
out how they made the pyramids but do
they know why they're shaped like that
or what they do I mean probably has to
do with this drill
or like you know cuz they well back in
the day alright yeah let me let me read
but I don't know if I'm taking this too
serious
clearly the stars were way more
important mmm and there was no
electricity therefore the sky was like
when you go camping and there's no light
pollution and you see the sky it's like
mind blowing for us that was what they
used to see every night that's what you
would think had spaceships and things
there's evidence nuclear blast how is
there not right forever ago
how is there nuclear bombs when it's
like wait what yeah what's that what's
that there is I can't do justice cuz I'm
actually in history what semester I'm
like bad at remembering dates and names
of places right I'm serious
anyway I love it it's it's it's I want
all this [ __ ] to be true an ancient
nuclear blast explain that don't believe
that like it's like never-ending nuclear
volcano that spirits get through I
obviously have no idea what any of
Scientology have you watched any
actually not it's a lot of it's like she
said it's a lot of it's you know
reaching but there are a few episodes
that they come along you're like that's
really interesting like people who live
in America like everyone in the city of
Senate there's so much evidence and yeah
you see one video that's super blurry
yeah okay just tell me this
we got a big beautiful round earth with
a billions of inhabitants where's just
one piece of like titanium alloy office
spaceship or nuclear bomb it's an area
51 the government as well said that now
the Trump is President does no way would
have kept any secret so we would have
known if they weren't hiding something
hmm that's actually such a great bit
like as he would have blown it although
in this UFO
I was watching they were saying the
president is exact
he's at he's just like this a need to
know yeah he don't need this is dark
when you see like real-life ones there
is a theory that JFK was murdered or
assassinated because he wanted he found
out about some of the alien evidence and
really wanted to inform the public and
he was assassinated it was on in the
most recent season of ancient aliens
they did an episode that address it well
I'll tell you one thing I don't believe
in many conspirators but JFK was
definitely [ __ ] murdered well yeah
I'm so block out that yeah I mean like
conspiracy
obviously he was murdered yeah for
purposes no that one's definitely
interesting that was just weird and wild
I don't know why is it why would it be
such a secret that no one about JFK no
the government is hiding so much like
why wouldn't they give you like a little
piece of information but you don't know
the whole story trying to strip the
people of their power maybe well I think
also maybe to avoid like mass chaos like
in that episode I'll if I base
everything that I know or care about but
they alluded to like some radio show in
like the 60s or 70s it was just like a
short story basically about aliens and
people thought it was real and started
[ __ ] panicking wait are you talking
about the War of the Worlds
I don't know when George when uh his
name Orson Welles did the radio race
something like that and people start
freaking the [ __ ] out right and so like
if you let this be public information
this [ __ ] with everyone's dream you're
like okay jesus is coming back he's
gonna come down and save us all of
you're like wait Jesus is a [ __ ]
alien yeah what the [ __ ] yeah I was on a
way cooler planet that's like in the
Bible but it would in theory maybe cause
mass yeah I understand that although to
be fair that Orson Welles one he was
reading War of the Worlds and he was
saying there's giant aliens blowing up
[ __ ]
he's saying that someone just donated
$1,000 why couldn't ignore that we'll
talk about that I guess afterwards okay
one derail the conversation I'm gonna
have to spend it on buying the first
several seasons of this show the JFK
stuff is is weird because his whole he
wasn't just assassinated his whole
[ __ ] family like but all of his
brothers were taken out they like killed
off the whole thing
yes yeah Tupac was never that way to add
it was him yeah it was a holic oh he was
always a whole rehab was able to take
the form of one we're creating a theory
right now I think I think we're giving
that technology too much got it all
right cool how do you move on past this
I just want to talk about this more
pretty great it's funny how much we talk
about it for to people who don't believe
in anything I just really want to
believe it's not really cooler than
aliens being out there and coming and
visiting but here's another question
like to kind of counter the whole point
on a high level why would aliens want
anything to do with this [ __ ] like
if they all have the technology to
travel interstellar space like what was
so interesting about Earth like clearly
they're one of many intelligent
forms of life so what's so special about
well the terraforming theory is that
that's where like a project yeah that's
okay existed and they come hang out and
check on us their social experiment we
are they're like children or they know
that were the most primitive species
that they have discovered so they can
check on us so they do just scientific
yeah maybe they have the advancements
that just like stop by uh get out of you
like oh the troglodytes on earth are
still just being idiots it's legit it's
the Joey salads alien race of social
experiment I love it well see pretty
soon I mean we've got [ __ ] in space that
we sent out there that's outside of our
solar system now some some thing we
launched in like the 50s this furthest
known thing we've Saliva's it's like
just past Pluto and exited the entire
solar system and there's no like how is
that connected to anything is there any
way to NASA have so yeah yeah they get
like it's so far away that it takes like
three days to communicate so it's
basically three light days away
wow you guys saw interstellar I love it
yeah great movie freakin loved it do it
when they're on that planet and like an
hour's like what is so cool
yeah I loved it yeah I love x-files too
so truth is out there by II terrified so
scared I just wanted them to [ __ ]
honestly and on the show bring it back
man if that show existed during them the
age of the internet you know Mulder
Scully porn would have been like number
what's that honestly there's probably
fanfiction right now the people are
currently writing the catch last time
yeah the show actually had like a second
wave of like I feel like it's in now
came back yeah well they did they
brought back a new season didn't they
nobody
good great I just re-watched old ones so
I know how we segue off this topic
mm-hmm
I find it interesting that you just you
when you post your YouTube videos
you don't make custom thumbnails right
no you're probably the biggest creator
and one of the few people who'd do that
I love it there was a hot second where
Julian was like I can help you make it
thumbnail because I always just let it
like generate one and then if it's
there's like all where my eyes are
closed or something's weird
I'll make one but no it's not like the
title and stuff on there you'll just
pick a screenshot that's as far as you
go but um there was a hot second where
Julian was like I'll help you make a
thumbnail it's just like this like span
of videos where I think it's too much
should it work I don't think it made any
difference
I just think yeah I mean it was the
Ariane that do you have yeah like well I
mean I think obviously it helps like if
you're starting to grow your channel or
you want to grow your channel it does
make a difference and that's part of the
you know issue now is people it's like
saturated and it takes a long time to
get to a point where people can see you
like you know in the past it was like
once someone sees your videos or knows
who you are you have an easier time it
was like more democratized but now there
is that like barrier to entry even on a
democratized platform yeah and I do
think that they help people get noticed
in a sea of [ __ ] crap the thumbnails
not even click baby but later so good
effort into it um I just don't do it
someone [ __ ] want it that's really
interesting so I like spoil the video in
the thumbnail I hate that right like
when someone's doing something
ridiculous and you want to watch it and
see it but then you already see what
they [ __ ] did I hate it like there's
an element of surprise I have no reason
to watch it what I already saw what you
did right you know I'm usually the one
making the thumbnails and it's so
stressful the titles - yeah oh my god
it's like
you Kurt you work all week on this video
you're like [ __ ] I've to actually put it
in title this thing just wanna upload it
already by the time you're done and then
only we start thinking about the Tom
know this whole thing you got good at
the thumbnail game though game
I find your approach interesting cuz it
kinda almost feel like it's more
effective because the thumbnails on
YouTube have gotten to a point where
they're just so outrageous it's also
what people have come to expect from
yeah yeah well I mean there I always say
this but like you know if you line up 10
youtubers in a room and ask them like
their advice of what to do they'd all
tell you 10 different things like
there's a lot of different ways to
navigate this space right and this is
just the way that I have chosen where
it's like I don't want to clickbait you
I don't want to you know thumbnail I
don't want to be crazy I don't want you
to be like oh my god I want you to know
that this is like a real thing you know
like there's a level of authenticity to
it yeah most definitely why I'm not
trying to like I'm trying to rope you in
around for a while I'm [ __ ] 30 like
you're either here right now are you not
you know so I think it's all just a
really a reflection of the person who
does it I don't think there's a right or
wrong answer yeah but I do think it's
kind of appealing just like oh here I am
here's my video mm-hmm anyway let's take
a quick quick brief break to go to the
bathroom you guys want some water some
coffee yeah it's like 90 degrees in here
actually it's not that bad but it's
probably our problem so we're gonna take
a quick break um and think our sponsors
you guys do me undies ready oh yeah
these softest underwear on the planet or
universe and that matter aliens came to
this earth and they created it for one
purpose to bring us to the pinnacle of
our existence and to create me undies
because they are soft and let their
luxurious you want to look good in your
underwear and be comfortable right but
that perfect balances are defined
sacrifice style or comfort check out
Mandy's comm / h3 and find the best pair
of underwear in the world they are truly
the softest in the universe
oh yeah let's see here
now this this underwear if you're
doubting me is so soft it's three times
softer than cotton
it's called modal right micro moto
listen if you've never rubbed sweet
modal on your skin or your jewels or
your ladies give it a rub not like a
sexual I mean just like walking you know
it's a rubbing so if you go to me undies
that's not that's not right now man this
has an exclusive offer just for our
listeners get 20% off your first pair
and free shipping capisce my knees is so
sure you'll love their underwear the
email four hundred cents get
satisfaction guaranteed your order of
bear and if you don't love it you get a
full refund that's a great deal it's
pretty much no risk you get to rub your
junk on some soft material if you don't
like it send it back no you keep it I
don't think you send it back they used
to do that they used to have days to
take returns on the underwear yeah they
stopped the export yeah straight into
the furnace but now you get to keep them
which makes sense so there you go it's a
no-brainer guys 20% off free shipping
hundred cents satisfaction guarantee and
what are you waiting for get 20% off
free shipping you go to Mandy's comm /h
3 that's Mandy's comm /h 3 thank you so
much to them and next you guys play card
games like hers fun oh [ __ ] but des des
has a card game that's the next five I
played it
have you played it's like Elder Scrolls
yeah yes but hearthstone
actually that's your sponsor yeah
ok I got the I finally logged in that's
what I was doing the whole time holy
[ __ ] hi just a small donation
oh oh it's a company um amazing huh I
don't know they do it'd be great if you
could check it out we'd love to have you
on Bart okay I'm a Z you got my
attention
you got my beanie wet so some company
name of a Z just gave us a thousand
bucks thank you to them I'll definitely
check my email
Jesus so we have Bethesda to think who
makes the Elder Scroll legends you guys
are really you're playing a card game
really it's free to play it's awesome I
really like it I think it's a it's an
exciting change from the other games in
the market it's got different roles it's
exciting the coolest thing is that you
can play it on your tablet your phone
your computer and if you disconnect you
could switch you can go on your other
one dope it's right now it's really fun
it's called a legends of the Elder
Scrolls yeah Elder Scrolls legends set
where there's a semicolon in there what
yeah that semicolon I don't remember
where it's in there just take those
Elder Scrolls legends Bethesda they have
frequent updates they've got this thing
called Lane system so you've got two
different lanes which is very different
than other card games adds to more
strategic play I think it's more Paul
honestly I think it's more polished and
fun to play than the other ones I've had
a lot of fun playing it I've been
playing it non-stop ela hates me I don't
spend time with her anymore because
Frank is the meta game's always changing
I recommend it it's free guys just give
it a shot these guys are the bestest
Bethesda for Christ's sake I mean have
they ever steered you wrong
don't answer that it's good port Mme
have it for me yeah they have a story
mode PvE they've got this thing yeah
this PvE arena so you don't have to play
against each other anyway go to the des
des dotnet open your account appreciate
you
and lastly our merch oh yeah we've got
our own merch now h3h3 shop calm I feel
bad because what you think turn a little
to the side hell yeah oh [ __ ] it up
either holy h3h3 shop calm Oh sir it
comes directly from us there's other
great samples here yeah take pictures
boy eat it up that's nice h3h3 shop calm
it's our own merch it supports us
welcome back guys do the H Street
podcast here with jenna Marbles and
Julianne solo Mita what kind of last
name is that tell him okay that's nice
go let's move on to the next good talk
Italian you got some Italian blood yeah
good for you thank you
you tell young food Italian food I like
Italian food grew up eating a fair bit
of it how much Italian are you have
right as Italian it's so fun to meet Ali
and I feel like it's like whoo yeah it
could be
Israeli it's like I think Italian person
once said that probably it's been said
before maybe this is the worst
conversation ever
Israelis are like Italians but not
really they are though they have that
like swagger I guess right eula has well
good sweat yes wait four days so we are
gonna take some Collins okay somebody
here we've got arson on the line who's
got a comment about the flippin
conspiracy theory so let's see arson
what up pimp nation did it work
all right obviously this is new to all
of us
move to history podcast arson what up
him nation cannot hear him dad oh my god
yeah don't call it oh hello you got a
question about the space travel or
aliens what's up yeah that's the same he
made a speech about a secret society
ring where he got says and it's there's
like a full video where you can watch
them listen to the speeches of
incredible event I had a quote and a
question if you didn't minds I don't how
much how am I good yeah go ahead
so the quotes basically he precedes it
by saying secret the secrecy is a huge
threat than public information so that
goes the very word secrecy is repugnant
in a free and open society and we are as
a people inherently and historically
opposed to secret societies to secret
oaths and to secret proceeding and that
was pretty much before he got his head
blown that is kind of create interesting
like that the timing on that also why
would a president even give a speech
about secrecy like yeah I mean it came
out of nowhere I mean obviously they
think he got killed because they opposed
the Federal Reserve but there's a lot
more to it and he used the word secret
society very clearly it's very just
surprised it wasn't like talked about or
at the time I mean I don't know if it
was but if that was a conspiracy at the
time that would I feel like that would
raise more flags like it gives a secret
sound like man these secret guys and
then gets killed can you look up the
secret try to find that speech actually
why might you do came in put on the TV
dan can you do some research out there
what else we got here someone else had a
question about um space memes well I
mean what's interesting about that I can
bring him back I would love
but so he was saying that a secrecy is
against like our democratic society oh
he's here yeah sorry
go ahead Jenna oh no that so if you buy
into the shakespeare francis bacon
theory he basically did it with the
intention of bringing language and
culture to europe so that they could
colonize America as a masonic of russia
crucian society Wow
so it basically was built on a level of
secret miss right so maybe it's not
really true that the United States was
built on secrecy being against the law
because some people think it's very much
part of our mmm culture but that's if
you buy into that well I don't I don't
understand the whole Masons thing either
what it was to deal with that should as
a whole that is a rabbit hole that is an
actual secret society that exists and
members are in it mm-hmm
but it could just be a bunch of dudes
like in their underwear drinking beer
right you're in it yeah you don't know
unless you're in it I think you have
like the Bohemian Garden you follow that
although I've never heard really that's
the RZA that's the weirdest one oh okay
this is one either was friends with some
dude in college and he his whole final
project was like he remade the Bohemian
cart bring me and grow grow grow and
it's actually a real thing there was did
you watch house of cards yeah there was
a scene where he went to the book you
mean so it's like politicians and [ __ ]
yeah so this is a real thing yeah every
year this most powerful people and the
United States are in the world men only
mmm-hmm interesting flow fact meet in a
private woods in Yosemite and they burn
a giant wooden owl tight it's basically
a wild party yeah it's a wild party but
in the show they just depicted as a
bunch of old farts like taking pisses
next to each other right that's not a
fact that it exists residents go there
ya know
it includes
artists musicians just power as well as
many prominent business leaders
government officials US presidents yeah
of course they all go man it's a giant
they probably [ __ ] like crazy they're
each other getting out all those desires
how do you how is it proving that it's
been you know somebody and why oh they
know where it takes place and then it
happens every year okay yeah it's not a
secret it's not people from crashing it
I guess I saw there's like insane
security yeah that's what we try I got a
driver you're an outdoorsman right
a drone let's test this conspiracy let's
see what happens that's crazy though did
you want to take it yeah I got it right
all right let's take so arson what is
your question yeah how you doing
incredibly transparent at least how far
are they gonna go you know what I mean
like you can justify any conspiracy at
this point because in at least a little
bit because it's so obvious that these
like happens step after step like he
makes this speech he doesn't all these
things and he gets killed its whole
family gets killed like you said yeah
JFK in my opinion is one of them
the most overt examples of some
conspiracy because it's just so
heavy-handed it's like this whole [ __ ]
family line got murdered some Game of
Thrones chit there so did you have a
question yeah those basically just how
far they like how far would they go is
incredibly you go thanks man appreciate
you thank you god bless ya papa bless ya
all right cool we were trying to think
how can we set it up so we're actually
just using discord yeah and then we have
dudes outside screening calls and then
if they like the call the bring if it
sounds like a say cuz you can't just
bring rim yeah tonight but we did have a
call last week and the connection was
bad yeah there was like a three second
delay and it was bad so it's kind of
imperfect some beta
yes beta it's definitely tough but it
works you guys want to take another one
yeah so how far do they are they gonna
take it that sounds like a very the
wording of that is like how far are they
gonna take this [ __ ] yeah how's the far
they can take this [ __ ] far as I can see
yeah who are they hold on Dan state wait
we have three people in here I probably
shouldn't be the one doing this okay
vehicles let's see what bagel man's got
going on bagel man talk to me tell me
about yourself who are you what do you
do hello hey how's it going it's going
great
[Laughter]
absolutely fascinating question Dan hit
the fast landing button don't let him
down dude all right so if you are
allowed to put any information about the
human race on a plaque that goes on a
new Voyager probe in the future or some
equivalent of a Voyager probe what would
you put on that plaque for aliens to
read that one dem haters iPod a being on
the haters has to say thanks good
question bagel man appreciate you let's
discuss that so what would you guys
write for alien civilizations in the
future so yon dead one sentence about
the humor information data oh one piece
of info yeah [ __ ] just probably like
some really nasty scat porn yeah just a
URL just one of us shitty and other
persons because you know what you
remember that Stephen Hawking was like
we shouldn't be sending [ __ ] out into
space because we don't know who's gonna
find it and come [ __ ] with us yeah
send one of us shooting another one's
mouth they will be like I'm going to the
next one what if they're into it that's
like they're gonna dump [ __ ] from there
these people like [ __ ] I'm gonna do my
favorite it's kind of a hard question to
answer seriously I would put some dumb
[ __ ] I know my role well I'm just dumb
[ __ ] I throw and picture my hamster out
there this is cute yeah this is totally
adorbs I mean we did blast we did blast
some [ __ ] into space like our Carl Sagan
did that like new years ago they put
like a equals MC square they put like
prime numbers repeating to be like hey
we know how to do that they were like in
the universe finding that information
they'd be like [ __ ] we [ __ ] know that
yes I'm [ __ ] dumb idiot thank you for
blessing me let's send them papers a
hamster yeah you're right look what we
got down here if you're and you're
capable enough to package a picture of a
hamster into a tin can and shoot it
across the universe you know how to do
prime numbers yeah somewhere along yeah
yeah the system is flawed all right we
got any more calls keep them coming dude
yeah it so we have my work we've got
Monster Mash uh sounds like trouble with
me Monster Mash - talk to me Papa bless
you how you doing Doug how you doing I'm
doing good I'm great man where you from
I got a question I was wondering to
people taking as much conspiracy
theories if you guys if you guys could
come up any theories of drive ooh
we have Oh
hey that's a great question thanks for
mean some of them I don't think I can
say I want maybe after the show some are
about you - yes oh yeah I have a lot of
yeah but like it's hard to talk about it
and you feel like you're shooting
yourself in the foot a little bit well
yeah if you believe in the conspiracy
one of the and then yeah if you talk
about it you're at the center you have
to get marked as like a dissenter yeah
we don't want to get marked do you want
to get murder no I don't wanna be marked
I've been marked D marked and I think
I'm mark yeah I do but someone's taking
my mouth at YouTube they do you marked
me but I need to kiss the ring again
next month
yeah I mean I've to answer your question
I've come up with something but they're
mostly about like this space right
probably shouldn't say in you know what
I think I know exactly what you're
saying and I and I have the same
thoughts yeah and it feels dirty saying
it yeah but you know it's true I think
we all can kind of gather at the same
vibe because we don't play the game
right you know like a lot of youtubers
do so we're able to put together some
pieces and it's really not even a
conspiracy there's so much evidence out
there I don't know I'm gonna say
something that I know okay it's public
information and I think it says a lot
I'm not saying that this applies to
whatever you guys are talking about but
to me it says a lot about how Google as
a company alphabet you know is run at
Google they have a chief one of the
highest ranking officers there is the
officer of diversity so what is their
like what are they a charger basically
just making sure that their employment
base is like representative of of all
diverse people okay
but it just seems like a strange like
that's their job that's the soul that's
he's done she's the officer of diversity
that's it that's their whole job is to
basically say how my white people do I
have how many Asians do I have very odd
and I don't know what they do but that's
just I mean because then you get to
thinking like do they just fire white
people bad there's too many white people
or black people or Asians anyone or
women or men it's just a weird thing to
think about but then you also think if
Google does it and user does it other
companies have to be doing it maybe yeah
yeah no you're right and the thing is
like um would you guys follow this whole
Google memo fiasco which one it would
blow up like a month ago where this dude
he wrote some paper a memo that was
passed around Google where he's talked
about some kind of gender role issue and
they were having like secret new where
he was like this is why there's a wage
gap and this is why women are typically
like this or something like that
something like that yeah well he was
what he was talking about that they were
having secret diversity meetings usually
they record their meetings but in the
case of these diversity meetings they
were not recording them because it's
technically illegal to just you know
base hirings on things like race and
gender even if you're trying to like do
the right thing or whatever so he was
just like what is going on here anyway
he's fired I don't know if you guys
followed that whole story a little bit
yeah all right where am I
we have got lon egg on deck to give us a
question what up one heck yeah what's
that oh it's all good
what do you got for us let's talk about
space I got a question about like space
and stove and colonization
is everything okay out there was that
him screaming oh my god that you're on
the show go ahead dude I'm I'm I'm
loving it colonization with possibly no
guarantee of coming back would you know
you talking about like the one-way
ticket to Mars yeah yeah like a cold
it's like the interstellar question cool
thanks for the questioned I appreciate
you very much I know my answer
[ __ ] no yeah that's are you kidding me
that's my answer
like I don't even like leave my house
like I can't not like not be with my
dogs
[ __ ] no r.i.p on earth out here if I
ride it to the end right or dunno I
could see myself in another life maybe
doing it but I also like the idea of
other people doing it for me doing the
claim freaking camera okay yeah that's
dope yeah from Mars first person on Mars
not even click baton and parentheses not
Clinton to me I mean it like it goes
back to watching interstellar like cuz
watching them and everything goes back
to it yeah well they made that scenario
a lot more like okay this is what it
looks like
yeah and man no way leaving no way or
there's both Matt Damon what was that
one man the marsh a Martian that's a
great movie I thought it was probably
pretty accurate representations yeah
yeah well I mean it's hard to know but
yeah that's what I thought too
yeah it just feels like you have to be a
very very specific type of person ya
wanna do that with your life and death
cuz that's what you're doing you're
signing your own that shirts not for me
I know my role I glue I [ __ ] glue
[ __ ] to my face okay I'm not here to
like make the human race any better
distract you from a weird [ __ ] that's
fair and that's an important job are you
doing here on earth oh yeah
would you do that ela what scenario like
it's cheesy to say but probably if I did
if I wasn't in a relationship yeah
that's one big or if I like didn't have
people I care about it family or
something yeah I guess more like I can
see and understand the type of person
who would want to do that yeah cuz super
like someone who would want to become a
Navy SEAL right it's like an adventure
of a lifetime
look I want to make a mark on on
somewhere along the road you're gonna
realize not an adventure though and then
you die like it is it is you know
they're giving their life for the better
or the good right yeah very I am NOT
made of that cloth no I just want to
play poke a pizza in it but I don't like
my urge and life is to resist eating
pizza that's my challenge yeah but by
the way um
Burbank is on fire what the [ __ ]
there's a fire in Brazil Burbank is on
fire and we're seared talking about Papa
John's what's the news
what part Bourbon oh my god dan can you
get a headline and pipe it down when you
get it is it like a wildfire or like a
power plant that burst up in flames like
that was happening in the Inland Empire
couple days ago like he was turning off
the power maybe yeah
that's are we doing are we did we do
something wrong god I think we thought
you mad at us
alright let's let's get some updates on
Burbank here why don't you pipe it into
N you got the mic I think I got to mic a
voice of God what's the headline
let's see brush fire breaks out in tunic
you know yeah I know where that is can
you unload your brushfire
alright brushfire got it I bet you can
see if you have just a brush fire now
but Latina Canyon is close to population
center so they're like doing evacuations
right house I think it's at the heat
where people things just start want
Annie asleep combusted yeah no it feels
like getting punched when you walk
outside by the heat there's like it
costs right there's like nice heat and
then there's heat where it's like I feel
like I'm getting cancer right now yeah
that's how that's what it is outside I'm
here yeah so hope everyone's okay yeah
we stay safe out there people pick up
your hats at a fresh calm yeah yeah
actually not you can't buy me
questionable but it was all fire so far
you know what I love about interstellar
a lot of people complained about that
movie but I loved it I loved how they
represented the black hole - yeah yeah I
like that a lot
so thought-provoking like my god
Christopher Nolan's a trip Doug they're
an inception by the way it's lit he's so
lit I'd abs on all the hey he's a
regular dabbing we got any other Collins
from y'all I do want to ask you guys as
is a regular segment of our show ghost
stories hmm so me Neal are skeptical
obviously we're haters we hate
everything clearly spent enough time
with us now today to know that you're
not haters you just you're very rational
I'm skippering yeah yeah I think I'm
skeptical to a fault to be honest it's
kind of annoys myself sometimes
James like the opposite yeah I'm like
everything excites me so tell you you
dog grass please well you go stories
really so we always ask our guests
basically you know if you have any ghost
stories because seems like a lot of
people have some interesting
supernatural encounters and it's didn't
we have like like talking about
like that we saw together or like
thought we saw like in our room or was
that maybe that was just a dream I
thought we had live chats a recent one I
had one when I was younger I went to a
know her story is [ __ ] terrible it's
not that terrifying but I liked I was
done after that it was like this is a
thing I went to an all-girls like
sleepaway camp but I don't know like
maybe 13 and it was at wells College
which is in upstate New York and you
know you get there and they're like oh
it's haunted there's all these ghost
stories that they tell you and [ __ ] and
you know all those are whatever but I
was sort of okay that's cool I'm a
little creeped out but like I'm not
totally bought in and one night I was in
my we stayed in dorm rooms and my
roommate the other girl who was there
with me she always used to fall asleep
before I would and so I was just
starting to laying in my bed and I
couldn't fall asleep and I saw like a
yellow green cross on the wall and all
the windows were shut I know it's
[ __ ] weird no sense and then I was
sort of laying there like you you sort
of have this like you're paralyzed with
fear like I can't I couldn't scream I
can't like yell to my friend like you're
sort of just like waiting to see what
happens and I felt and saw something
like depressed in my bed like someone
was sitting on my bed and just this like
terrifying feeling and someone's just
sitting there [ __ ] staring at you
and then I woke up the next morning and
my friend actually was not asleep and
had seen the cross on the wall - I was
like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what kind of
structure were you guys in it was a dorm
you were in a building and projected on
the wall was some kind of glowing cross
mmm did it look like a projector or was
it just coming out of the wall was there
windows yeah the we had windows but the
blinds were shut okay and it was a
distinguishable crime and she saw the
same thing and was also spooked at the
same time yeah the the impression on the
bed is what gets me it there's no
feeling like that like you were cuz
I couldn't move it's like you're
paralyzed with fear it's [ __ ]
terrifying
how old were you at the time like 13 and
so you're in your bed and you see like
the blanket go down as there's somebody
sitting there yeah did you sleep at all
yeah I eventually fell asleep like but
that's the thing it's like when your
crease ever lifts I don't remember it
looking at all yeah but like what I
remember was like just being there with
fear like I don't even remember falling
asleep I don't remember ever coming out
of that state of fear or like anything
it's like your adrenaline is like
through the roof and then you somehow
just like pass out and wake up the next
day it was the most [ __ ] bizarre
thing in the world and then I thought it
was crazy and I was like last night I
saw this [ __ ] cross on the wall she
was like I saw it too I wasn't asleep
but [ __ ] over [ __ ] was that a relief
to define I saw it could you like I'm
not insane yeah actually happen she
couldn't have pulled off some elaborate
prank right no mm-hmm she's terrified
yeah that was about it
I have no goes because there's nothing
no should go out there and get one I've
tried we went because possible on one of
our friends is like a huge ghost
enthusiast he's a believer and so I was
like dude you know take me to the
spookiest place smart guy and so he took
his out there and I mean you know we
heard a couple of scuttles if this ghost
is so spooky and and powerful that it
can't even like get my attention above a
rattle and a bush or a scratching sound
then he's a he's a [ __ ] people it
takes a lot of energy for them to like
manifest if you buy into that right like
so is it just ghosts or is it do you not
believe in like demons or anything
though no I don't believe in it here's
it again a [ __ ] Ouija board and
played another believe in demons what's
it Oh what is it called we actually have
so yeah like I forget we did a podcast
on it but it's a common thing that
happens on Ouija board when you're
actually you have to buy into all of
this okay just for a second like it's a
common thing that happens on the Ouija
board where it goes back and forth and
spells zo zo zo or like Bo Bo Bo and
call the entity or the demon Zozo or bo
bo because that's what it keeps spelling
yeah but it's also a theory that it's
just whatever spirit or entity is
playing with you that by going back and
forth back and forth will actually like
open the portal early so this is it's
just their way of getting in I kind of
so anyway once class culture all it
happens like multiple people so whatever
you like it seems like it's a really
fluid motion with your hand right yes so
it seems like could almost be a natural
the most how are the laws organized yes
yeah it is right mmm so it's not QWERTY
they don't think no it's not for you
it's not no yeah should be do you like
[ __ ] what up so I don't know there's
like this this thing okay
outcomes raise it right which is like
the most the most simplest way the thing
with the least amount of sumption x' to
make is probably most likely to the
explanation so when it comes to
something like UFOs and seeing a light
in the sky what's more likely like um
[ __ ] guys club I don't know whatever
[ __ ] they say mmhmm but just some
[ __ ] in the sky or interdimensional
intergalactic aliens visiting they're
obviously like the inadvertent light is
more likely way more or less yeah like
astronomically
but doesn't mean it's the only possible
no certainly not
yeah wait so is that that's how I
suspend my disbelief most the time I was
like well that that clearly isn't
probably the best explanation like a
sigh like I heard a rustling in a in a
bush
was it a lizard or a [ __ ] demon
trying to get my attention right he's
clean obviously did I see you late in
the sky are you kidding me I'm like
that's a [ __ ] alien dog like I'm so
thirsty to see some aliens like
everything's an alien I want to see it
well we had a friend in Israel who was
so obsessed lone yeah yeah with the idea
that he saw an alien nothing I could
ever say I mean but then that's like the
thing if it's happening to you you can
only convince people so much I mean this
is what I think right you have that
experience to draw from where you have
that visceral like emotional response to
something that you can't really describe
past just like telling people what
happened all right so like for you that
story about the impression in your bed
like it sounds scary to me but you have
a completely different yeah
memory of that because it was like it
happened here right you doesn't believe
in ghosts at all no do you both but it's
are you less skeptical than okay what do
you think happens when you die okay the
most likely answer is nothing right
describe it wait describe that well the
Mokka like everything ends you're just
you know we're we're I'm I can only
confirm that I exist like that's all I
know right so I think that when the
lights go out for you in a sense the
universe ceases to exist because I'm the
observer of my own universe but like
before we were born we were already
non-existing dead for you know 12
billion years we would just be returning
to that same state of from which we came
which is pretty much nothing right
nothing is I I don't think it's the most
the nicest thought in the world you know
but on the other hand I can see also
because the universe is so weird so
weird that anything exists at all right
like
also as a trip like it doesn't matter
how rational and sane or not but how
rational like skeptical you can be you
still need to acknowledge how [ __ ]
weird it is like that very concept of
existence is so on the other hand like
I'm fully aware of my limitations of
knowing what's out there and like the
idea of God is something that not not
like a biblical sense or religious sense
but higher there's stuff there's like
higher power is it's hard to explain
that away yeah so maybe there's
something after death but I don't think
it's the most likely explanation if
there's anything weird like the way we
are in our dimensions we can't
experience more than this moment but I
think eventually you die but if you
could see like more dimension you could
see like your whole lifetime yeah like
how time is it that's what it is but we
can't see it yes the dopest basically
that theory which is like three more
dimensional is basically there's no such
thing as death yeah like you're living
every moment of your life
simultaneous yeah but we're in slices of
time dimension so you're not aware that
is shrinkage like maybe I don't know if
it's necessarily yeah it's probably I
don't know that it's really interesting
the multi dimensions yeah so what about
you boy Elon Musk when he talks about
that our consciousness is like a semi
like your soul or something if you die
your consciousness your mind couldn't
Theory be like uploaded again back into
the matrix so it like your soul what
makes you human or Ethan your
consciousness never dies but your
physical form dies and you just get back
well that's like the Buddhist
reincarnation may I love dad every crime
it's like but it's like we incarnation
great but like with someone
orchestrating it above you or your
consciousness exists somewhere they need
to recycle your consciousness if you're
just running in a simulation but imagine
if you're like some rich dude in another
[ __ ] you
and you're like you know I just want to
go back like it's like you're playing
pub G right now that's like what person
yeah like they want to the part I wanna
I want to pay my way back on earth and
like have some earth experience like we
could just be like doing the miners day
we're using so you're saying
consciousness are beamed into our body I
mean I but then once you're in the body
you don't recollect being a alien God or
even like we're in each other time
you've been in this AI simulation with
your consciousness it's like a game they
did a Rick and Morty talk about that
what was it yeah oh god I forget the
name of it but they there was this
arcade game and like this alien store
yeah and they like beam you into the
game and you've you've lived this full
rich life like a whole life yeah
you get married you have kids you die
and then you come out you're like no
that was a good round yeah that seems
like I like the idea of the simulation
it seems somewhat plausible though that
it we're all running in a computer
simulation just like and it's experiment
yeah I feel like it's an interesting
experiment to see what involves see what
we do it's pretty [ __ ] crazy right
that's the blunt yeah but see like the
problem is if you believe to have a in
that then like Scientology is sort of
like you're an infinite being that like
you know the people that are around you
don't even really matter like if you
really buy into a little too much and
you're like a crazy person UPS doesn't
value human life that is true [ __ ]
dangerous puffiness sociopath yeah it's
not for sociopaths to talk about like
I'm just I'm just a player in a game and
everyone else's NPCs like I see what I
do in Skyrim to those NPCs man I do not
want to be in that game [ __ ] this girl's
life all those poor guys all those poor
NPCs man all right what else where you
go from here
it has been two hours has it been I was
waiting to see if one more person comes
in but I see there's two people in the
screening room mm-hmm it's so fun that
you guys get calls yeah that's right I
figure it out it's actually cool yeah
and so cool I'm thinking about actually
getting like a classic call switchboard
that'd be cool
yeah I'd be really cool and be a little
more yeah yeah that would be cool I'll
call him you gonna call him how much
rejects you a million I love that that
one like Howard Stern is doing a show
and like his like his mom always calls
and like there's people that always call
in all right thanks for inviting that it
will thank you thank you thanks for
saying that
appreciate it yeah it's nice it's nice
to be over that let's go set ourselves
on fire by stepping out into like oh my
it's basically like yeah it's what was
that movie Total Recall when they step
outside of Mars and they're like heads
blow up and they catch on fire is that
yeah that's what we're living in LA
right yes
[ __ ] all right well thanks everybody for
watching right you guys your YouTube
channel is Jenna and Julianne right if
Jenna Julianne podcast annejulien
podcast if you guys want to listen to
the podcasts check it out there it's a
lot of fun catch up on all the
conspiracy theories I'll turn you into a
believer man
no alright well see you guys next time
[Music]
you